so I was just sitting here working on
hazel and I figured now would be a good
time to do one of these hazel dev logs
what's up you guys my name is the Chinna
welcome back to another hazel dev vlog
let's talk about what I have done if
anything the last couple weeks have been
pretty rough in terms of hazel work
because I'm getting into the into some
of the more gruesome paths making a game
engine isn't easy I've said that before
a lot of times I don't think I need to
say that for you to realize that but I
will say it's also an incredibly
rewarding experience because I feel like
I'm finally getting to the point where
you can kind of maybe make something
with hazel what I wanted to talk about
specifically today there was the
importance of debugging and I don't just
mean debugging is in fixing your code I
mean obviously that's important what I
mean is creating debugging tools along
with what it is that you're doing so
normally the way that I like to work is
that this is camera crooked normally
when I'm writing a feature that is
moderately complex I like to make sure
that I am aware of what is going on it
sounds really simple but it's something
that I can't say everyone does
unfortunately a lot of people seem to
just try and write code or copy and
paste code from other places and just
kind of jam it in hit f5 they see it
running and then they move on to the
next kind of stage or the next feature
that they want to add but that's not
really a good way to write code and the
reason is that if you don't understand
holistically what is going on with the
piece of code that you've written or
copied and pasted from somewhere they
have little probably issues with it and
those issues are probably gonna come
back and either by you or your player if
you're making a game at some point in
the future this absolutely doesn't just
have to apply to code that you've copied
and pasted from somewhere and thus you
don't know how it works this can apply
to your own code as well once you start
working on some fairly complicated
features you might get to the point
where you're not even sure yourself if
you understand what you've done and what
you've written even though it it seems
to work but fortunately there's almost
always something you can do to
understand the prob
better whether it be putting up some
graphics on the screen that help you
actually visualize what's going on or
just making sure that you're printing
the right amount of debug information or
just providing as much feedback for
yourself about what the computer is
actually doing as possible and a good
example of this is something that I
ended up adding when I was dealing with
the scene system that I'm dealing with
right now what I've added into hazel
over the last couple of weeks
specifically I've made it a lot more
robust but the biggest problem that I
had that I talked about in the last dev
vlog was what happens when we hit play
and we want to actually play at the
scene the thing is we don't just want to
enter a place safe and then play the
game and then enter like an edit state
we want to be able to essentially fully
reset the scene when we play but playing
a scene is something that is quite
complicated a lot of things will happen
when you hit play
there could be physics simulations
entities are scripted they can be
scripted through c-sharp so they could
create other entities they could create
or remove components you know you have a
full kind of simulation of like a world
going on how do you how do you stop that
simulation and go back to the edit scene
and that's quite a complicated thing
because there are a lot of features that
you actually want to have running in the
editor even though they might be part of
the actual runtime of the game for
example with the whole scripting system
you need to be able to see what public
variables your scripts have so that you
can easily set them per entity from the
editor that requires the script engine
to actually be up and running and then
what happens when you hit play and then
stop again and then play again and then
stop again it didn't trust me it gets it
gets complicated one thing that really
helped me when making sure this system
of mine was working was just making sure
that my data structure which was like a
map of a map of a struct which had a map
of a map inside it as well as some other
data I mean
and it gets deep making sure that I
could actually inspect that entire data
structure in I am GUI so that I could
make sure that I was aware of what was
going on by being able to actually see
what what was even inside that map of
map of map of maps now that itself was
just so useful and I could immediately
spot problems with it so the moral of
the story is if you're working on
something complex if you're working on
something that you feel is way over your
head take a breath
don't try and set artificial deadlines
for yourself if you're just working on a
hobby project try and take it slower and
actually make sure that the code that
you're writing is not just the code to
solve the problem but code to make sure
that you understand what's going on and
code that will help you debug the
problem and make sure that your solution
is actually working correctly I think
that if you take the time to lay that
groundwork you're gonna have a much
better result because just like building
a house on a foundation that's
completely weak is a bad idea if your
foundation is weak all the code that you
keep piling up on top of it it's gonna
be a mess anyway just some things to
think about let's take a look at what
I've done so like last time we basically
have this blank scene I'm gonna go file
open and I'll open this pink sunrise
modified scene which isn't even pink
sunrise but anyway we have this scene
here we have an entity I'll select it
and move it into the middle just to get
it a little bit better I've got this
outline effect that I'm currently
trialing I just added it now it's just a
slightly better kind of selection to let
us know what's going on so what happens
at the Mormon is I've got a camera in
the scene I've got this test entity and
I've also got this what's called empty
entity I was renamed it sphere because I
think that's stupid so with these three
entities this test entity has a script
on it that does a whole bunch of things
and in fact a lot of this was just me
testing public variables but if I
increase the velocity this is
essentially just a vector II that I'm
adding to the transforms position every
frame if I hit play now you'll see that
this will actually move and I can
actually click on test entity I can see
everything happening I can manipulate
these variables in during the runtime
and everything is pretty cool don't mind
the rotation going up these again
there's just random variables that I'm
testing if I hit stop now you can see
that everything goes back to where it
was that's pretty cool but before I
continue I'm going to talk about this
script engine debug panel which
just kind of leave over here this is
what I'm talking about this was me
adding the debugging support you can see
that what this actually has is a list of
sins this is the actual script engine
runtime and this is that map of maps
that I was talking about we have a scene
here and under the scene if I click on
this sin we have a list of entities that
actually have script R on time so if I
look at the test entity the test entity
has a script component that means that
it is actually it has to be registered
through the script engine if I look at
the test entity that's the module that
it's using its called example dot script
and you can see these are the public
variables that we've exposed through
c-sharp now when I hit play and it
starts playing the scene you can see a
new scene gets created because this is
the scene that we're currently playing
and it also has like a runtime version
of all of these things now the intended
behavior here is when I have stopped
this scene should get destroyed and
everything here shouldn't cease to exist
but what actually happens as you can see
is if I hit stop the scene actually
remains everything else gets dropped
which is correct but I'm actually
leaving behind an empty scene and you
can see that every time I hit play and
stop here well it's just creating more
and more scenes this is what I'm talking
about something like this I don't think
I would have ever picked up because the
only reason I would have picked this up
is if I put in some kind of breakpoint
somewhere and I inspected the map
through my debugger and I saw that all
this same map is huge it's got so many
scenes in it whereas it really shouldn't
have more than two and since each time
we hit play it creates a completely new
runtime scene with its own kind of
identifier they're never really going to
clash and it's never going to run into
the problem of this scene already exists
but by seeing this visually by being
able to visualize this data structure
and I am gooey and seeing what's
actually going on you can see how much
inside this this actually puts in there
are a few other things that this script
engine debug panel is really useful for
the camera entity here currently well it
doesn't have any behavior associated
with it but what I can do is add a
script component to somehow try and
define some behavior for it I've got
this c-sharp class here called basic
controller which has some very basic
behavior you can see it's got a public
speed variable here that's exposed into
the editor and then an update function
that basically responds to the user
input and assess the transform it's in
the namespace example and it's called
basic controller so I should be able to
add this into my camera
script compartment if I go back to hazel
here under module name inside this
script module of added and currently the
only way to really do this is to type in
the name so if I type in example dot
basic control and you can see by the way
that it's read at the moment because
there's nothing there's no module
there's no class matching this name yet
if I finish typing it you can see
immediately we get that speed variable
and if we inspect the scene I think it
was this one you'll see that there's
also now the camera entity is inside
this scene and here we have example dab
as a controller because now this camera
script component has been registered
with this basic controller script and
now it exists inside the script runtime
so this also was very important because
you can see if I get rid of it and start
typing something else this is now gone
there's now neuro script associated with
this whatsoever
but if I bring it back there we go it
appears so I can set my speed to
something like five and if I hit play
you can see I can now move using the
arrow keys and if I go back to my camera
component I can adjust the speed to
whatever I want and move this around so
this is all working correctly so moral
of the story is visualize your data it's
really really useful one other thing
I'll show you guys is another pretty
cool thing that I've added which is the
ability to actually hot reload these
scripts so let's say I wanted to do
something fairly simple with this sphere
maybe I just wanted it to kind of sink
overtime just kind of gravitate
downwards there's no script that does
anything like that
so if I go back to visual studio under
source I'll add a new item here and
we're going to actually write a
completely new class and we'll call this
sync I'll put it under the example
namespace I'll add an on create function
although this isn't really required it's
going to do anything and an on off date
function which takes in a time step I'll
expose a variable here called sync speed
it'll be a flirt and then copying some
code for the translation from my basic
controller class and making sure that
I'm using the hazal namespace we also
need to make this an entity I should now
be able to just adjust the Y translation
by subtracting the sync speed times the
time step every update all I'm going to
do now is build this entire solution
here which is really just the example
app DLL and now back in hazel I can hit
file reload c-sharp assembly and just
like that I should now be able to add
that script component here so we called
it example dot sync you can see it
appears in media
we have our sink speed variable I can
set it to a value here and if I hit play
you can see that now we have that
sinking behavior for the sphere I can
also click on the sphere while it's
running and change this to like a
negative value or something like that
and it will float upwards and if I of
course stop it everything will reset
back in camera I could also adjust this
and change this to be the sink and now
the camera will just sink as you can see
it's actually sinking at the same speed
as the sphere so that might be something
you want to change but ultimately there
we go so I'm really excited about all
these changes because as you can see you
can start piecing together a dynamic
interactive seen inside hazal which is
super cool as hot as it is working on
this stuff I think it's really rewarding
when you get to a point where things are
just kind of start to work it's really
cool to see and it's very motivating I
hope that you guys enjoyed this video
don't forget to hit the like button if
you did if you are interested in hazel
and you would like to support its
development please check out my patreon
in the description below also have it on
the screen apart from getting access to
all of this source code in its current
state you'll also get access to weekly
live streams where I develop this kind
of stuff so if you are interested in
that and want to help support the
development of this or use it for your
own purposes then please help support it
that's pretty much all for me let me
know what you guys think of this if you
want me to talk more in depth about a
specific thing then let me know what it
is you want me to talk about I said
there was a lot to say about the various
scene systems and scene serialization
and there's just so much stuff to talk
about and I honestly want to but I also
have to remember that I'm sacrificing
development time to make certain videos
and a lot that's why I think a lot of
them dude turn out to be just these
rambles from me and I don't know how
many people are interested in those
specifically but the thing is if I sit
down and actually plan a good video of
how like the same system in hazel works
that's probably around a day just gone
and I mean I'll enjoy that day don't get
me wrong but it's also a day that I need
to think about allocating specifically
for that and not for working on
something else so these kind of chill
videos are a lot easier to make and
if you do want to hear me talk about
something specific or even give you a
bit of a demo I'm definitely gonna do
that soon
once I polish this version of hazel dev
up and it can actually be used to make a
game I'm gonna probably try and revisit
that flappy bird game that I made in an
hour but try and actually do it through
c-sharp using some of these things I'll
also probably be adding physics
components soon anyway thank you all for
watching have a great day goodbye
[Music]